vous avez le droit de parler pendant
qu'on regarde les il adore on y va ouais
on y va alors c'est un magnifique flanc
aux drones avec une image inversée en
post-production ensuite pour les gens
qui m'ont demande comment on a fait ce
plan
j'ai opté pour le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
de générique parce que je pense que
d'abord ça coûte beaucoup d'argent de
fer les génériques et maman on les
regarde plus les génériques puisqu'on
binge
et là on va découvrir le personnage de
apache joué par clément qui fait partie
de mes trois héros des newcomers que
personne n'avait vu à l'écran avant
[Musique]
tu braques l industrie manuel jamais
mende hier j'ai commencé en mode bloc à
venir alors les lumières c'est très
inspiré d'une série que j'aime beaucoup
qui s'appelle gomorra très assumé
voilà et le jeune homme qui va qui
frappent à la porte
c'est un jeune comédien qui s'appelle
brahim c'est aussi son premier tournage
et on arrive dans les locaux de skyrock
et c'est dans ces locaux de skyrock va
arriver le début de l'intrigué de cette
série alors moi je joue ce personnage là
qui s'appelle dj snow qui est un dj
beatmaker producteurs et qui sont qui
font un peu partie des grands manitous
de ce métier c'est des gens qui est qui
qui trouve les instrus qui trouve les
mello qui qui fabrique les tubes en fait
que que les jeunes écoutent et puis dans
cette émission de référence qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle planète rap qui
est l'émission de référence du rap en
france va se passer quelque chose que
j'ai souvent imaginé en allant mois en
promo là bas c'est que je m'étais dit
quand il ya des mecs qui appellent pour
faire un freestyle parfois il avec son
super des mecs sont moins bien et puis
je me suis posé la question qu'est-ce
qui se passerait si le mec qui au
téléphone on lui dit bah c'est super
peut-être qu'on se verra un jour et puis
lui dit je suis en bas est-ce que je
peux monter tout de suite il monte et un
événement va se produire c'est qu'il va
y avoir un clash entre deux bras deux
sens que je vais vous non mais je vois
là et donc c'est le point de départ est
là le point départ arrive très tôt